[Musik]
nein die Ultimate Venom hat das Spiel
betreten und video
kannst du dich bewegen hat Siri
irgendwas eingestellt dass du nicht mehr
laufen können
wie kannst du denn so schnell sterben du
kommst auf den Server und bist TOT los
Bruder kannst du laufen nein ich kann
nichts ich bewege mich nicht von der
Stelle woran kann das liegen dass die
beiden nicht laufen können
[Musik]
einen anderen Skin geht doch ich kann
nicht gehen Bro warte mal ich
teleportiere mich mal zusammen Sandra
Digger ja ich kann mich nicht ich kann
nicht weglaufen was soll denn das diese
können wir uns ja nicht bewegen ein paar
Sekunden später
[Musik]
Idioten
gespielt ja guck mal Idioten wie blöd
ihr seid
[Musik]
Leute was geht ab ich bin's Marvin ich
bin
prank mal wieder peace Leute was geht ab
[Musik]
Kuss Digger selfie dein Haus ist immer
noch am Arsch ne du hast in die Luft
gesprengt
kleiner Hund
ist neben dir eigentlich noch mein Bett
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie denn ja ich komme zu dir warte wir
gehen jetzt in der Höhle wir müssen ja
auch ein bisschen wir müssen jetzt aber
wirklich ein bisschen Vorankommen
bleiben Sie doch mal bitte stehen
[Musik]
oh nein hast du ein Bett dabei
ich habe nicht mal ein Schild aber ich
Idiot
das ist eine ganz ganz gute Idee dass
ich hier gerade in der Höhle bin was geh
mal schlafen
concrafter kill Hilfe
[Musik]
eine Ewigkeit später wenn man
theoretisch einfach sagt die Villager
sind jetzt Gärtner oder wieder dann heiß
dann kümmern die sich um den Scheiß hier
ja okay krass da brauchen wir nämlich
mal wieder einen mit okay ich habe einen
ich fahre wieder nach Hause
drei Monaten
bist du verloren das ist mein Boot nein
du Trottel
also sorry
ja und jetzt halt die Frage um welches
fällt er sich kümmert
komm mal hierhin wer
[Musik]
hört ihr beim Hausbau helfen
das
[Musik]
ich bin Level 30 aufs Handy ich kann dir
was verzaubern
das coolste alles klar okay ich habe
hier das relativ gutes für dich Sandy
ein Bogen mit Unendlichkeit das ist
schon sehr krass der ist nicht so krass
wie meiner aber wie gesagt das war
geisteskrankes Glück was ich hatte aber
du brauchst jetzt nur noch einen Pfeil
Thomas selfie
das ist der Bogen
und das hier ist ein Pfeil immer die
beiden Sachen auf
was
wenn du mit dem Bogen jetzt schießt
brauchst du nur einen Pfeil du hast nur
einen Moment habe du kannst unendlich
oft schießen
hey und wie ganz normal
ob irgendein Ziel gucken dann einfach
schießen ja besser nicht auf mich
du willst diesen Stress nicht du weißt
das selbst ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine Steine
ein anderes Haus gehen sowieso noch was
zeigen wollen würde sie wird dadurch
nicht sterben aber das hoffe
irgendwie ein Creeper rein gelockt hat
also Leute Sandra aber da gerade weiter
ich weiß nicht will ich bin aber gemütet
für Sie und werde jetzt dieses Haus hier
so umbauen das sind zwei natürlich hier
reinbekommen
[Musik]
und der Boden hier auch aus Stein sein
wird hier
drunter
ein TNT
und eine Druckplatte und jetzt Pranken
wir Sand und gehen auf endlos Handy ja
ich habe eine Idee aber wir wollen ja
alles zusammenschalten also guck mal
mein Plan ist ne
man kann ja hier die Treppe runterlaufen
und dass ich dann so ein Weg hier an der
Seite rein mache wo hier dieser Weg ist
weil wir haben hier noch zwei so Häuser
von village an
[Musik]
dass wir die halt theoretisch gesehen
die Häuser hast du noch nie gesehen
auf jeden Fall
gelockt
habe oder
[Musik]
hä guck doch mal rein
wie findest du mein Eingang voll cool
oder
das war nicht zu werden ich bin so müde
ich merke das ich bin richtig
unproduktiv
ja Ciao die sagt einfach
Stream aus sieht so aus
[Musik]
wie beendet einfach ihren Stream so hey
Leute ich bin tot müde es tut mir
unfassbar leid ich muss unbedingt
schlafen kriegen deswegen werden wir
jetzt wieder einen ganz kleinen Streamer
reden okay Leute haut rein
[Musik]